this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespaces the all-in-one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below more on them in a bit
at the moment of his death it's likely
that william mckinley assumed his name
would live forever as the 25th president
of the united states mckinley had helped
steer his nation out of its worst
economic slump prior to the great
depression he'd overseen a victorious
war against a european power shepherded
through the annexation of hawaii the
purchase of the philippines and
supervised the creation of an american
empire at home too it was popular the
first president to win consecutive
second term in a quarter of a century so
when he was gunned down by a terrorist
in 1901 it must have seemed as if future
generations would revere him alongside
abraham lincoln but of course that's not
what happened today william mckinley is
largely forgotten by the general public
known merely for being the guy whose
death propelled vp teddy roosevelt to
the white house if he's robert at all so
how did this happen how did a man whose
presidency seem to usher in a new epoch
slide so gently into oblivion today
biographics is telling the story of
william mckinley the forgotten architect
of the american century
given how anonymous he is today it's
fitting that william mckinley's early
life was so marvelously obscure born on
january 29 1843 in the small town of
gnars ohio young william grew up the
seventh of eight children doing all the
things that boys did for fun in the mid
19th century swimming hunting and
learning to ride a horse his parents too
were utterly ordinary his mother had
about christian while his father ran a
small foundry it wasn't enough to make
them rich but it was enough to make them
live without worry average as they were
though there were two things that marked
out the boy's parents as unusual one was
a ferocious belief in the valley of
education although they were happy in
gnarls mr and mrs mckinley hated the
idea of their kids growing up
semi-educated ignoramuses when william
was just 10 they moved to the town of
poland just so that he could attend
private school but it was the second
notable thing about his family that
would have the biggest impact both mum
and pop were ardent abolitionists this
was a time when many in the north
campaigned against slavery's expansion
but stopped short of wanting to outlaw
it in the south the mckinleys by
contrast drilled into their children
that slavery was evil that it was worth
putting your life on the line to help
eradicate it and those beliefs would
soon have a profound effect on young
william's future in 1860 a combination
of illness and financial troubles forced
16 year old mckinley to leave his
college and return home taking up work
as a postal clerk to make ends meet
barely had he settled into this role
when news reached ohio that a south
carolina militia had bombarded fort
sumter kickstarting the civil war within
weeks mckinley had signed up joining the
ohio 23rd regiment determined to do his
duty a duty that he'd carry out with jaw
dropping zeal as a private mckinley was
almost suicidally brave gaining a
reputation for riding through dense
cannon fire to deliver urgent messages
he served at antietam still regarded as
the bloodiest single day in u.s history
where he charged through heavy enemy
fire to deliver supplies to union troops
it was antics like these that brought
him to the attention of his commander
rutherford b hayes 20 years older than
mckinley hayes regarded all his men as
family treating them with a respect that
was legendary but he seemed to have a
special affection for the young man from
gnarls after antietam he placed mckinley
on his general staff by the time the war
was over he seemed to consider the lad
an honorary son for his part mckinley
returned home with the rank of brevant
major for the rest of his life those
closest to him would refer to him
affectionately as the major yet while he
might have returned to civilian life
mckinley wouldn't go back to his pre-war
job back in ohio the young man opened a
law practice in canton becoming locally
successful but the real change would
come courtesy of his new mentor in 1867
rutherford hayes came to mckinley and
basically said young man i've decided to
run for governor fancy doing my dirty
work something for hayes that year was
mckinley's first brush with politics and
evidently he liked what he saw after
hayes won the younger man threw himself
into republican politics in 1869 he was
elected prosecuting attorney at stark
county and while that might seem like a
minor post to start with it really was
just the start now had gotten a taste of
it mckinley wouldn't be content to just
sit around with his thumb up his bottom
in stark county
oh no instead he was going to take that
butt and that soiled thumb all the way
to washington
soon snow actually asked him we can't
say for certain but it seems likely that
mckinley would have regarded 1869 as the
greatest year of his life that's because
1869 wasn't just the year he moved into
politics but also the year he met ida
saxton highly educated and extremely
progressive on rights for women and
african-americans idaho was everything
mckinley dreamed of in a partner the
pair met at a picnic that summer by
january 8071 they married just 11 months
later on christmas day their daughter
catherine was born not long after in
1873 their second daughter followed but
if 1869 was the highlight of mckinley's
life 1873 would represent the blackest
depths just four months after being born
their youngest daughter died around the
same time his mother passed away and the
combined tragedy seems to have broken
her for the rest of her life ida would
be crippled with depression depression
that only got worse when their daughter
catherine likewise died in 1875.
combined with a sudden onset of epilepsy
the mental breakdown helped turn her
into an invalid someone in need of
long-term care and care for her william
mckinley would throughout the rest of
his story even as his star rises even as
he becomes president mckinley's number
one concern will always be ida for some
members of the public this was
scandalous for others admirable but it's
unlikely the future president gave a
damn either way for four short years he
and ida enjoyed a perfect life in return
he would now stand by her until the
bitter end not that his extra duties as
cara would get in the way of mckinley's
rise the same year his mentor rutherford
hayes decided to run for the white house
mckinley ran for his own seat in
congress so loyal was he to the old man
though that he took time off from his
own campaign to stump for him evidently
he didn't do any harm that november
mckinley won a seat in the house of
representatives a seat he would hold bar
a brief period following the 1882
election for 14 years in a whimsical
little twist mckinley celebrated his win
by sticking a scarlet carnation in his
lapel a fashion choice that he kept up
for the rest of his career it would be
thanks to this that ohio adopted the
carnation as its state flower in 1904
but while mckinley had definitely won
his congressional run the same can be
said for hayes the 1876 election was the
tightest in history with just a handful
of contested electoral votes separating
hayes from his democratic opponent after
a bitter political fight the democrats
agreed to drop their claim to those
all-important votes in return for
president hayes ending reconstruction
for a supporter of african-american
rights this was likely a nasty blow to
mckinley not that he was brave enough to
show it though throughout his time in
washington mckinley would remain on
hayes good side and in return the
president would help propel his career
ever higher by 1889 that included
reaching the heights of chair of the
house ways and means committee from
where mckinley was able to pursue his
pet project tariffs in this era the
republican party was broadly against
free trade preferring instead a form of
protectionism to help boost american
manufacturers mckinley was all in on
this believing aggressive trade policies
would help improve the lives of ordinary
people so much so that in 1890 he used
his position to push through something
known as the mckinley tariff slapping
import taxes on over 1 500 goods
mckinley confidently expected the act to
raise prosperity for manufacturers which
it absolutely did unfortunately it also
sent consumer prices skyrocketing the
hike on goods was so eye-watering that
it effectively dynamited the
congressional republican party by the
1890 midterms voters were so angry that
the gop lost 93 seats and control of the
house among those swept out of office
was william mckinley stung hurt mckinley
slunk back to ohio to run for governor
although he won it was hardly a
resounding success mckinley's margin of
victory was barely a polling error but
politics is a winner takes all game and
whether voters were enthusiastic for him
or not mckinley was now the governor of
the buckeye state it would be in this
new role that he'd soon meet the man
who'd make him president
so we'll get back to today's video in
just a minute but first here's a word
from today's video sponsor squarespace
you know what's great about the summer
bit of time off time you know to relax
but also while you're relaxing you're
probably going to be daydreaming maybe
that'll be about the next project you
want to start i just got back from
vacation certainly the case for me
fortunately squarespace gives you every
possible tool you might want to fashion
your next web project whether it's a
small business a sports blog a creative
portfolio or just a page full of dank
memes it doesn't matter if you can dream
it you can build it with squarespace are
you looking to get in and out quick
without thinking too much about what
your website should look like bam use
one of their quick beautiful templates
to make a website that's fresh and for
you or maybe you're more of a hands-on
person you like to have lots of opinions
and ideas about what exactly your site
should look like while squarespace gives
you all the customization options you
could ever want with no updates no
patches no technical bs to worry about
once you've done setting up your website
tinkering with the design if you're so
inclined or maybe just playing with the
colors there are so many extra features
that squarespace provides so your site
can thrive email campaigns patronage
portals social integrations member only
areas analytics commercial options 27
customer support everything you want is
in one place so start your new site by
going to squarespace.com and you'll get
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch your new site go to
squarespace.com forward slash
biographics and you'll save 10 of your
first purchase of a website or domain
and now back to today's video
mark hannah occupies a strange shifting
place in mckinley's story in the early
20th century the wealthier iron was
often cast in the role of puppet master
the guy who made mckinley president to
push his own pet policies today though a
more common view has it that mckinley
used hannah more than hannah used him
leveraging his patrons wealth to pursue
independent goals whatever the truth
there's no doubt their meeting while
mckinley was governor set both men on
the path back to washington but only
after fate gave a little bit of a
helping hand in 1893 the same year that
rutherford hayes went off to the great
ohio in the sky democrat grover
cleveland began his second
non-consecutive term in the white house
unfortunately for his party no sooner
had he started than america was walloped
by one of the worst depressions in
history the panic of 1893 collapsed the
economy unemployment jumped to 19 scores
of banks and railroads failed savings
were wiped out investors lost everything
among those nearly destroyed was
mckinley who'd foolishly co-signed a 100
000 bank loan for a friend when the
friend went bust mckinley was left on
the hook for the money luckily the uber
work the mark hannah stepped in to bail
him out and that left mckinley perfectly
poised to reap the depression's bitter
rewards with the economy in free fall
the electorate gave the democrats a
shellacking the 1894 midterms remain the
worst defeat of any party in an
off-presidential election year what the
republicans had suffered in 1890 the
democrats were now suffering 10 times
over and that 1996 was now looking like
an assured gop victory all mckinley had
to do was make sure that his name was on
the ticket by now mckinley was a known
quantity having chaired the republican
national convention and governed ohio
for years but rather than take his
chances he was determined to make sure
he was the delegate's only choice backed
by hannah's money and spin operation
mckinley ran perhaps the first
recognizably modern nomination campaign
in history one marked by
some interesting firsts perhaps the
biggest was his decision to speak to two
all black audiences while campaigning
the first white candidate to ever do so
yet it would be in the presidential
campaign itself that mckinley really
redefined what american politics could
be given the nomination that summer with
garrett hobart as his vp pick mckinley
launched what was then the largest
election campaign the nation had ever
seen backed by a war chest of four
million dollars the republican party
flooded swing states with political
leaflets mailings pins badges you name
it anything to keep their candidate's
name in people's minds mckinley himself
meanwhile took the old-fashioned front
porch campaign to a whole new level in
the months leading up to november he
invited a total of 750 000 people to
hear him speak and not just in any old
order across 350 speeches mckinley
tailored his pitch to different groups
to the traditional republican wasps but
also to jews to catholics to black
people to emigrate from portugal bohemia
germany you name it after decades in
which the two parties had come to rely
on their bases mckinley was trying to
build a big tent coalition one that
included as many traditional democratic
voters as possible for their part the
democrats put up the populist fire brand
william jennings bran but while he had
energy brown was playing an old game
preaching to the choir even as mckinley
was luring them away to his exciting new
chancel that november the results were
unambiguous mckinley beat bryan by a
margin of six hundred thousand at the
popular vote and nearly a hundred in the
electoral college for those of us alive
today used to reading about ronald
reagan's 1980 landslide or fdr crushing
it in 1932 mckinley's victory might seem
unspectacular but make no mistake in
1896 it was a political earthquake for
the first time since ulysses s grant was
re-elected a quarter century earlier a
candidate had won over 50 to the popular
vote the era of extremely narrow
victories was over mckinley had just won
the most convincing mandate in a
generation and he would use that to
completely upend politics
in one specific way the election of
william mckinley sparked the end of an
era upon his inauguration the 25th
president became the fifth and last
civil war veteran to reach the highest
office perhaps fittingly his time in the
white house would be dominated by
conflict but this time the fighting
wouldn't be taking place on american
soil but in the last reading outposts of
the spanish empire back in 1895 when
mckinley was still just governor of ohio
the people of cuba had risen in revolt
against madrid to which madrid had
responded by herding 300 000 cubans into
concentration camps an insane
overreaction that had done for spain's
reputation what the news night interview
did for prince andrews by the time
mckinley became commander-in-chief the
american public and press were demanding
some form of intervention at first the
new president kept things diplomatic by
gently applying pressure to madrid
mckinley got the spaniards to grudgingly
release the camp prisoners and grant
cuba limited authority this even led
washington sending the battleship maine
to havana as a sure friendship but then
the 15th of february 1898 rolled around
and everything went to hell that day a
mysterious explosion destroyed the main
in harbor killing 226 crewmen in the
aftermath the tsunami of anger washed
over america before an investigation
could be concluded the press was
whipping up further for war with madrid
not so long ago historians believe that
mckinley allowed this fervor to carry
him along dragging him into the war
before he knew all of the facts the iraq
war of the late 19th century but newer
scholarship disputes this version in
modern tellings mckinley did all he
humanly could to avoid war until it
became necessary desperately keeping
diplomatic channels open until spain
angrily cuddle contact whichever version
is true the outcome was absolutely the
same on the 23rd of april madrid
declared war two days later washington
did the same the first time america had
declared war on a european power since
1812. yet while the war of 1812 would
result in a messy draw the
spanish-american war would have a much
clearer outcome by that we mean the
united states absolutely crushed madrid
within days spain specifically had been
destroyed in the philippines not long
after the atlantic fleet was sunk near
jamaica and american troops were
marching on puerto rico cuba itself
former assistant secretary of the navy
teddy roosevelt victoriously led his
rough riders up san juan hill with
santiago falling not long after by the
12th of august spain had been defeated
and the war was over a war in which
mckinley had played a vital role using
newly installed telephones to talk to
his generals in real time and it wasn't
the war itself that so shaped mckinley's
presidency but what came after from the
ashes of spain's defeat the 25th
president helped build a true american
empire at the height of the fighting in
july mckinley had already signed an
order officially annexing hawaii now
with madrid defeated he oversaw a peace
treaty that expanded washington's
holdings further still under the terms
thrashed out puerto rico and guam became
american possessions and cuba was
nominally granted independence but in
reality was likewise drawn into
washington's orbit but the biggest
change was the purchase of the
philippines for 20 million dollars
madrid signed over its great pacific
outpost with that purchase the us became
a true colonial power mckinley
personally pushed hard for this
convincing the senate to ratify the
treaty with a two-thirds majority
convincing the house to appropriate
millions for empire building it was a
hugely divisive decision one which saw
guys like mark twain eviscerate the
president for wanting to emulate the
corrupt empires of europe but twain was
in the minority enthusiastically backed
by teddy roosevelt mckinley embraced
america's new role in the world a role
that would make it one of the world's
great powers a role that would also
involve some very murky moral
compromises
just as it's hard to make an omelet
without breaking a few eggs so too is it
hard to build an empire without breaking
a whole lot of humans in the case of the
american empire most of that breaking
came during the philippine-american war
having been freed from spanish rule a
lot of filipinos believed not
unreasonably that their islands should
belong to them so when uncle sam instead
rolled up and started draping everything
in star-spangled banners they tried
their best to fight back the result
kinley sent in an american occupation
force one that met the rebels with
brutal violence by the time the war
ended in 1902 it's estimated some 200
000 filipinos had died many of the
tactics that had so outraged americans
when used by spain on cuba were now
turned on the philippines with
predictably awful results yet the
philippines wasn't mckinley's only
post-war foreign adventure in 1900 he
committed troops without congressional
approval to the eight nation alliance
sent to put down china's boxer rebellion
it was a move that won the u.s a 25
million payout from china's
post-invasion indemnity while also
confirming it as a nation newly willing
to flex its muscle on the world stage
this is one of the reasons some call
mckinley the architect of the american
century not just because he helped guide
the country out of the 1890s depression
and into prosperity but because he set
the blueprint for washington's foreign
interventionist policy this was a policy
that would echo through world war one
world war ii vietnam iraq and beyond
still we don't want to paint his
presidency as one entirely predicated on
foreign policy even with the
conflagration that was engulfing the
philippines mckinley was likewise
changing things back home perhaps his
most notable achievement was to
concentrate power back in the hands of
the president following the civil war
the u.s had gone through an era when
real power seemed to lie with congress
now mckinley embarked on a great
centralizing drive making the white
house once again the first among coequal
branches paving the way for the
extremely active presidencies of teddy
roosevelt and woodrow wilson that would
follow speaking of teddy roosevelt it's
arguable that mckinley's most impactful
domestic decision didn't involve once
again raising tariffs or his laudable
hiring of african-americans into
diplomatic positions but simply giving
roosevelt a job back in 1896 the younger
man had campaigned heartily for mckinley
so much so that advisers wondered if the
new president shouldn't reward him
personally mckinley didn't like the idea
at all he thought roosevelt was too
pugnacious too unwilling to compromise
but he also recognized that he had a
sharp mind and was genuinely talented so
he decided to take a gamble on him
making him assistant secretary of the
navy that allowed roosevelt have a high
profile position to resign from when war
broke out allowed him to become a famous
hero at the head of the rough riders and
return to republican politics as one of
the hottest properties yet this would
still have been for naught and mckinley
not taken a second chance on the 21st of
november 1899 mckinley's original vp
garrett hobart died in office with no
25th amendment the position remained
open until the 1900 republican
convention by which time teddy was the
favorite to join mckinley's ticket
behind the scenes though mckidney's old
patron mark hannah was unhappy like the
president he despised teddy's macho star
in meetings he impressed upon mckinley
the need to find someone else
anyone else but mckinley knew talent
when he saw it putting his personal
feelings aside he threw his weight
behind the war hero for his vp pick and
with that one decision the 25th
president changed the course of american
history
the 1900 election played out like a
disney live-action remake of 1896 that
absolutely nobody needed to see once
again the democrats put up william
jennings braun once again mckinley
trounced him becoming the first
president to be elected for a second
consecutive term since ulysses s grant
this time however the epilogue would be
completely different recently the
administration had noticed mckinley
receiving an alarming number of death
threats in this era there was no
dedicated secret service detail to
provide security just personal
bodyguards who tried to urge the
president to be more careful around the
public unfortunately this was also an
era in which presidents were expected to
be approachable regularly seeing
chatting to citizens in the street when
mckinley's bodyguards asked him to be
less conspicuous he was basically like
absurd what america would ever want to
harm their presidents to which the
answer would soon turn out to be leon
cholgosh an unemployed detroit
millworker with anarchist leanings
cholgosh had gotten it into his head
that mckinley was oppressing the working
man and needed to be stopped and since
this was the great era of anarchist
assassinations cholgosh didn't plan to
stop mckinley via the ballot box that
september 1901 child gosh traveled to
buffalo where mckinley was speaking at
the pan american exposition on september
the 6th the president stood outside the
temple of music to shake hands with
passers-by despite his bodyguards trying
to get him to cut things short mckinley
insisted on continuing his greetings in
1607 the 25th president turned and held
out his hand to the next man jogwash
took it and with his free hand he fired
two bullets into mckinley's stomach the
pandemonium that followed was bizarre in
that unlike jfk or lincoln mckinley
remained conscious as it all unfolded
from his wounded position he begged the
angry crowd not to lynch joelgos before
turning to his private secretary a guy
called cortalu saying my wife be careful
what are you how you tell her
oh be careful in oddway it's touching to
see how he remained so concerned about
ida to the very end although everyone
realized this was really the end rushed
hospital mckinley was declared badly
wounded but likely to survive
transferred to the nearby home of the
exhibition's organizer he began to
recuperate for several days it looked
like it pulled through and then the
great horror of the pre-antibiotics
world reared its head
gangrene the infection that took hold
around the wound did what child rushes
bullets had failed to do on the 14th of
september 1901 william mckinley died in
buffalo the third president to be
assassinated he was 58. the reaction to
mckinley's death varied wildly by person
on vacation teddy roosevelt found
himself forced to hightail it to new
york to take the oath of office mark
hannah meanwhile was seemingly more
concerned about roosevelt's election
snarling i told william mckinley it was
a mistake to nominate this man in
philadelphia i asked him if he realized
what would happen if he should die now
look that damn cowboy is president of
the united states for his part leon
chulgosh never showed any remorse he was
executed on october 29th of that year
his infamy assured mostly though the
death of mckinley was marked by an
outpouring of grief once so vast it's
comparable to the aftermath of jfk's
assassination one that made it seem like
his name would live on forever instead
it was destined to slip into oblivion
today william mckinley sits alongside
guys like william taft and calvin
coolidge in the special category of
significant presidents most people have
somehow forgotten about despite
overseeing a successful war and dying
tragically there are main few monuments
to him even mount mckinley in alaska was
officially renamed gnarly by the obama
administration in 2016 and so mckinley's
great slide into anonymity continues in
many ways it's a pity although he wasn't
perfect mckinley oversaw a profound
transformation in american history a
moment when the u.s went from being a
regional power to a great power it was
sitting atop a global empire without his
lead the expansionist presidency of
teddy roosevelt would have been
unthinkable take teddy out of the
equation and you also have no presidents
taft or wilson and suddenly american
history starts to look really rather
different yet mckinley was more than
just a prelude to tdr in his unshowy way
he changed what the presidency could be
changed what america was how americans
thought about themselves and their place
in the world he may still be obscure
today but we are all still very much
living in a future that mckinley helped
create